make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
we're back to creating our own what-if
stories which i think is especially
important now because Marvel and DC are
not releasing any news stories which by
the way let me know what you guys think
down in the comments post some stories
that you think we should cover we are
gonna get caught up on x-men but aside
from that let me know what story you
think we should cover because I'm
considering covering executioner's song
there's no significance about the story
but it is cool and strife is like strife
was am a new strife manager they
introduced strife or the Marvel
Cinematic Universe man dude it was man
it would be it'd be a massacre anyway so
we're covering a story the x-men become
Red Lanterns so let's begin this right
let's begin this let's put this story in
the context of the greater Marvel
Universe so as you know if you've been
reading any x-men comic lately the x-men
along with all mutants on earth both
good and evil are currently residing on
the living island of cacoa or at least
most of the mutants that are out there
now since Jonathan Hickman took over the
x-men line of titles the mutants have
established their own nation on kokoa
and their relationship with other
governments of the world has been
tenuous to say the least now this really
comes as no surprise and is more or less
a microcosm as how the world has
approached the mutant race since their
introduction into the Marvel Universe as
being hated and feared by humans has
basically been the underlying theme of
nearly all the x-men stories that have
ever been told so that gives us a really
logical starting point for our
hypothetical story as now that the
mutants have their own country the other
nations of the world have an easy target
for the prejudice against homo superior
now one of the prominent features of the
x-men status quo on krikawa
is that anytime a mutant dies they are
to be resurrected through a process
involving of group of mutants known as
the five tempest Proteus Hope Summers
elixir and egg who was formerly called
gold balls but somehow finds himself
with an even lamer nickname now but the
whole process relies on egg essentially
creating non-viable eggs with Proteus
turns viable through reality-warping DNA
of a mutant is then injected into the
egg which elixir gives life to tempest
then speeds up the incubation process
with their time altering powers until it
hatches and all this is made possible by
Hope Summers empowering the rest of the
five to use their powers in unison and
at the peak of their potential through
her ability to mimic the powers of
others and push them to their absolute
limits and so for our story to get off
the ground
this
has to stop happening as this is going
to provide a catalyst that's going to
cause the x-men to choose the path of
becoming Red Lanterns so what happens is
that a covert team of operatives from an
unnamed organization finds their way to
kokoa in the cover of darkness they
destroy the stockpile of eggs that have
been created to resurrect mutants and
kill egg himself so that no more eggs
can be created thereby ending the
process a mutant resurrection however
the most egregious action taken is the
assassination of Charles Xavier
now while this has happened before since
the founding member of the nation-state
of Kirk OA at this time there is no
bringing Xavier back and as you would
expect the idea that they can no longer
employ this process to raise their
fallen as well as the murder of one of
their own is a source of great anger for
mutant kind there was the council that
governs kokoa gathers they decide that
the human community has gone too far and
that although they respect the dream of
Charles Xavier for mutant and human
coexistence that prompted one of the
principal laws of cacoa to be kill no
human the time for that cooperation has
basically passed and they must now set
their sights on revenge however the
council knows that lashing out at the
world will draw the intervention of the
non mutant heroes of the world and they
debate on how or even if they can defeat
them now it's at this point that
apocalypse reveals that he's been making
contingency plans for the day that his
fellow mutants finally saw the light and
realized that peaceful coexistence
between mutants and the inferior species
of humanity was impossible and so he
explains that he's found a way to use
the doorways on Kirk OA to go beyond
traveling from place to place to be able
to travel between dimensions and in fact
he's been making periodic trips to
another universe and has found an ally
in an entity called Atrocitus now he
goes on to explain that although
Atrocitus cannot come through the
Gateway to krikawa since he is not a
mutant that he's given apocalypse a
number of range that will grant the
mutants vastly more power than they
already possess what's more apocalypse
would say smugly these rings are fueled
by rage and when have we ever species
ever been more enraged than at this
moment if we take these rings no force
on earth will be able to stand against
us and we can finally take our rightful
place as the rulers of this planet so I
feel like apocalypse would talk that way
but I don't know but
see I don't know how to voice Apocalypse
he doesn't really need to be loud but he
doesn't really need to yell he just
needs to have that authoritative voice
but normally cooler heads would prevail
and the x-men would never do something
like this but their mentor and their
entire way of life has been destroyed in
an instant
and they are understandably angry and
the presence of the Rings apocalypse has
offered them seems to only intensify
their rage and so those who are closest
to Xavier of magneto Cyclops Wolverine
storm Jean Grey and basically all the
x-men take the Rings and recite the Red
Lantern oath as instructed by apocalypse
with blood and rage of crimson red
ripped from a corpse so freshly dead
together with our hellish hate we'll
burn you all that is your fate and so
those words prove ominous as once the
Rings are dawn the x-men are transformed
in a way turning into creatures
motivated and consumed solely by rage
with an insatiable desire to destroy
everything in their path no longer are
they out for revenge for their fallen
leader but simply in all-consuming need
to watch the world burn and so from
there that's where they set out to
accomplish indiscriminately traveling
the world leaving as much death and
destruction in their wake as they
possibly can now when news of the
rampage of the Red Lantern x-men reaches
the rest of the superhero community that
just sounds awesome Red Lantern x-men
like that just sounds amazing
now when news of the Red Lantern x-men
reach the rest of the superhero
community they immediately tried to
devise a way to stop them the Avengers
the Fantastic Four
Spider Man Doctor Strange literally
every superhero you could think of comes
together to try and stop the x-men's
wrath they meet the x-men with a united
front sparing no resource in their
offensive against their former allies
which have now been turned into mindless
monsters Iron Man in Black Panther have
brought out every piece of technology in
weaponry they have but the plasma
emitted by the x-men incinerates it all
as well as the entirety the entirety of
wakanda's forces Doctor Strange Scarlet
Witch brother voodoo every magic
wielding hero in the Marvel Universe and
even Doctor Doom who's temporarily
aligned with his traditional enemies to
save his kingdom of Latveria and the
rest of the world launch every magical
attack they can think of to no avail
despite the potency of their magic the
force power
the x-men is not of this universe and
the magic seems to have no effect on the
red light constructs shielding the x-men
now as the battle rages on the heroes of
the Marvel Universe begin falling one
after another before the Red Lantern
x-men those that are left begin
formulating a last-ditch plan to save
the world it's a long shot if something
they would never do under normal
circumstances but they see no other
option and so Reed Richards tells Thor
who's still serving as a Herald of
Galactus to find the devourer of worlds
and bring him to earth and furthermore
to take Franklin Richards with him Thor
does not like this plan Richards and and
Reed Richards will respond I don't
either Thor but this world is gone
either way
we cannot defeat them but there is the
lesser of two evils you'll just have to
trust me and so a Thor will respond I as
he would fly off with Franklin to summon
Galactus now in his absence the heroes
would fight valiantly but they would
continue to fall spider-man Captain
America and Iron Man are all among the
dead even heavy hitters like Captain
Marvel and the Hulk are unable to do any
significant damage to the Red Lantern
x-men when the battle is over the wet
Lantern x-men hover over a smoldering
earth having destroyed it all but in a
cruel twist of fate still not satiated
and craving even more to destroy
although nothing remains
and so when Thor reappears Galactus
appears with him and so our Thor would
say all right eater of worlds do it now
with that Galactus would consume the
planet and everyone on it
bringing earth-616 to an end once and
for all now as Galactus Thor and
Franklin look at an empty spot in space
for the earth once resided Franklin
sheds a tear for his family that had
basically just been wiped out of
existence now Thor would say I thought
your father said that you could fix it
and frankly would say I can I can make
things exactly like they were before it
will all be just like it was and no one
will know except for me and so with that
Franklin Richards makes the earth in the
image it had been before the x-men put
on the Rings before Charles Xavier was
assassinated and before apocalypse
figured out how to cross into the DC
universe and learn of the Red Lantern
Corps furthermore he creates a barrier
between this universe and that one
determined to keep the corrupting force
of the Red Lantern Corps or any other
force that may attempt to infiltrate
their universe from ever seeping in
again and so this universe has enough
problems
own and ultimately Franklin Richards
just kind of lets things go so yeah
that's how I see it playing out if the
x-men ever got the Red Lantern rings I
think they would be virtually
unstoppable and would lay waste to the
entire Marvel Universe so that the
easiest way to write that ship would be
to eliminate the earth they destroyed
and replace it so that no one would ever
remember what the x-men did and this is
kind of a cool thing here there was this
idea that I was kicking around with that
one Galactus and everybody showed up
that ultimately there would be like a
spare Red Lantern ring floating around
there somewhere who really knows but
like the Red Lantern ring would bond
itself to Franklin Richards and Franklin
Richards will become a Red Lantern ally
himself with the x-men take on Galactus
defeat him and then they would just kind
of go out into the universe and try to
destroy everything if you guys want to
see that story where Franklin Richards
becomes a Red Lantern let me know like
let me know and I will make that video
because I feel like it would be lit but
you'd be amazing right Franklin Richards
as a Red Lantern would be so open to an
end if you I know hear two comments
explain it make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the rob4 if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]